what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have my
little brother adam
stop it stop it on the channel um he is
going to be reacting um to my recent
live video with me before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos so i had a live and i just
thought some of the topics that we
talked about were like insane so
i'm gonna just
wait let me make sure okay i'm gonna
just go
position this appropriately i'm i'm
working right now folding some laundry
oh yeah
do you have a topic you want
we were recently talking about a lot of
different things like you and me
separately yeah
we were talking about dating apps
and you were like
um i met her in l.a
she does like she's a she's not
tick-tock you sent me that thing that
analyzes your dating app
my wife i wasn't great enough i think
that this is like a good um tool that i
feel like people show i'm talking to her
now about um
like a
a website that can rate your profile
pictures and i said it's good for dating
apps
i'll see you use on dating apps
um it's called photo feeler and like it
gives you upload your picture and either
men or women will like rank your picture
and give like
an analysis of how you come off to them
right so i mean i didn't like
i don't think you have to use it but i
was just like
you know i just think it's a good tool
because like a lot of times when like we
take a picture we have no idea how it
comes across to like someone else
but
i've never i had never heard of that
before
and
i i guess there's a disconnect for me
when you're like we don't know how these
pictures come off to someone else
because i'm like
why does it matter but i guess it
matters because you want people to like
your profile
right okay
sorry my finger i'll give you an
example okay a couple years ago i was on
a dating app
and um
i i matched with a guy and we were just
saying oh we should just like write like
tell each other how like to make our
profiles better right
and like say which pictures are like the
most attractive least attractive
whatever and he said oh you have too
many pictures like that look like you're
going out like i would just assume
you're a party girl
and like the way i was thinking was like
oh i only take pictures like when i'm
dressed up so like that's how it would
seem but i wasn't even like going out
that much
but like you have to remember people are
judging you off like a split second so
like that piece of information like
helped me completely change my profile
to come off like as someone like that
would you know look like more of a
relationship type of girl versus like a
casual
that's so interesting
yeah
and that's like
i'm like so sorry go ahead
um
i think i have a dece i have a mix
of somewhere i'm out and somewhere i'm
not but i'm i'm someone i'm always
taking pictures of myself yeah and i am
a party girl so
oh all your pictures make you look like
a party girl i'd be like and i am a
party girl yeah
if you want to date me like are you
coming to the party with me are you
going to stay at home like how does she
come off to you so far
i mean it's accurate
she just uh
i don't know
i think it's accurate so far in terms of
you
it how it shows off i think it's a lot
less accurate for women because like i'm
not gonna lie when i look at most
females tint drip profiles i'm only
looking if they're hot or not
i'm not checking right because that's
not what i'm looking for i'm not looking
for
relationship and tinder i'm looking for
but if you were looking for a
relationship right you keep looking at
their profiles more or no yeah which i
do agree with i think that is true um i
think i'd actually look more into who
they are okay versus but i also think as
a guy i don't i'm not gonna look that as
deep yeah oh of course like you're gonna
see a me with a bow and you're like oh
this dude's a [ __ ] hick and then well
i think i think as a girl um
like you'll have
what's that i don't know okay we're just
gonna ignore that um
i think like that this app would be way
better for guys than girls because girls
are way more picky all right
right
right
yeah i just uh
yeah i guess if that's like
like do you find that like then you get
more guys that are interested in like
casual stuff because like
i've just heard from guys like that they
just assume like the party girl like
that's fun that's not something they
want long term
i would have to like send you
screenshots of my my picture so you can
see okay
now when i guys that are that want
something casual i just unmatched them
like okay
like
i can find out in the first couple
passes of the conversation
like if they're serious usually the ones
that are casual are the ones that are
saying send me your address i'll come
over or
[ __ ] on what well see no i didn't
i called [ __ ] that you could read
every conversation within the first few
passes i think that's that's the
[ __ ] i don't think most people know
what they want going into the
conversation
so
i think it's however well she's a little
older than you too yeah you know what
i'm saying like i think like a 45 year
old probably knows what he wants yeah
that's true
because she's 30. yeah so
versus like a 21 yeah like of course
okay okay
netflix until they immediately start
saying saying something sexual they send
you an emoji and like i just don't even
entertain that and match them yeah no
that's fair enough i just think like for
me it'd be easier to like have a wider i
mean like okay if you actually are a
party girl then that's fine like that's
what you represent you know but like for
me like i think it helped because like i
felt like i could give a more accurate
like depiction of who i am and like you
also would be surprised like what
pictures the guys rank is higher like
one picture they ranked me one to ten
they gave me a four another one they
gave me an eight same person
right yeah yeah so i was just saying
like it's best to pick the hottest
pictures of yourself oh yeah i'm not i
don't edit my pictures so i don't i
don't think i like portray anything
that's not real right
but like you know like i think it's
better to have more attractive pictures
yeah well like two the two photos i've
taken with her the one she took last
weekend was much better than the one
matt took of us at the sushi restaurant
like
it it just is the lighting was awful in
the photo and she kind of looks like a
demon in it yeah the other one it looks
nice right yeah well that's what i'm
saying like like you can look completely
different just based on lighting like
lighting behind you versus in front yeah
you
judge yourself too much off of what
other people judge you by what
i think you judge yourself too much off
of the way other people judge you
oh but i feel like but like i think like
you should like
yeah like on some level otherwise you're
just going to be delusional like
like
how can you go through life and not
think what anything anyone says has any
validity you know
like
i don't know i just like live in this
like blissfully ignorant world of like
my way or the highway yeah
yeah well i just think like in dating
like it's kind of good to know like
i don't know how like
like where you fall a little bit so like
you know what you can get for me
at least
exist what some aspects yeah but like
there is a line up you have to draw
where it's like
this is who i am and i don't really give
a [ __ ] what you think oh no i agree what
i meant is like
you'll see later you'll see later like
why i'm like talking like this
um
what i mean is like you have girls that
come in saying like i'm a 10 i'm a tet
like
[ __ ] you're not like clearly you're not
a ted yeah like like that's what i mean
like a lot of women i think are like
delusional
like and girls we like gas each other up
like you know you're you know your
friend's fat like
like stop
stop gassing her up and tell her she can
get like chad and tyrone on the football
team like she can't tell her to go for
someone in her league like you know what
i'm saying yeah
like like you you clearly can tell when
there's a guy that's only talking to a
girl for sex
yeah because he's way more and that's
what i'm saying as a girl you should
know a little bit
where you fall so you don't get used
like find someone in your price range
i'm not saying like
put yourself on sale but know where you
fall you know
like in terms of like your
attractiveness
yeah like um
yeah pretty much
i just always started i hit on the
highest guys
what i hit on the hottest guys i always
just like something um it was
it was a frat frat guy story and him and
his buddies had this plan and so he
actually dated he had a consistent
long-term girlfriend who he she knew all
about his schemes and all his ploys but
what they always did whenever it was
just him and the boys was he went out
and always aimed for the ugliest girl in
the group
that way he could kill all the other
girls self-confidence and he was a very
good lucky man like he was like and so
he would go for the just immediately
every single time like he'd interact
with the other girls but like just fully
engaged with the ugliest girl make it
seem like that that's who he wants
except like other girls are trying for
him it's like they're all like very
where did you hear this i read it was a
frack guy story oh okay and it's like it
it was it worked i could tell you from
yeah watching it it happened um
and he
like i don't know how to put it but like
it was just impressive because
it worked for his buddies perfectly
every single time because all the girls
would immediately be like i'm not good
enough for this guy so i guess i'll go
for the second or the third or the
fourth oh cause he was he was in a
relationship so he was like trying to
set up his friend right and she knew all
about it like her girlfriend approved
because she understood exactly what they
had goal was yeah
it was just entertaining to watch how it
happened because it was very clear on
what would go down
okay
no okay so
that's interesting well that's why like
i'm gonna be honest out of like if
there's a guy that's like a certain
level of attractiveness like too hot i'm
like oh like
he probably just like it's trying to
um guard at the top like if you're hot
like you're for me
oh well then i'll just like move on to
the next one
yeah
yeah
yeah
um
i mean i don't know i just think like
it like i'd rather come off as an eight
to guys than a four so that's why i like
the app of course
i said you're not a four like ever
you're like
what
you can't worry to me this is delusional
yeah in a bad picture i am before i
don't know why that's so like
yeah like i'm not offended like if i
look homeless like i clearly don't look
like
me most of the time
i don't always help myself
yeah you're kind of cut in and out i
don't know if it's your end or mine and
i've been getting text messages i know
sometimes when you i need to explain to
you my scale by the way of how i rate
people and looks because i think people
think i'm rating myself harsher than i
am
okay now this is this is what i mean
eight to ten you could get a modeling
contract
like that's this is just your face
nothing else not body nothing else
included so if you're an eight or higher
you are at the point of getting a
modeling contract i don't believe in
sevens because everyone thinks they're
seven so you gotta pick you're either a
model or you're not a model right so
most people are fives and sixes
average slightly above average a girl
that's an adjustable six is an eight on
her best day dressed up she's an eight
does that make sense yeah so like girls
it's adjustable like i think like a girl
that's a five can be a seven to eight
on her best day
best day
does that make sense with you know good
body everything so when i say like four
that just means slightly below average
like if you like
that's nothing like i'm not trying to
does that make sense yeah but like
everyone can't like all the homeless
people videos
like after the guy does all the shaving
and cleans them up and it looks nice and
grooming like
that's just that's like a very clear
example of it it's adjustable that's
what i'm saying like it's like a guy
it's it's not so much like a girl it's
more her body that makes her adjustable
a guy a guy it's more his like
ambition hair yeah it's like facial hair
and hairs money right yeah so okay when
someone's messaging you it messes up the
signal on here annoying maybe sub five
like honestly like a three or lower you
just gotta be like you had to have done
something to yourself or just be super
old
like oh super old you can still be
attractive you just not take care of
yourself yeah yeah but you get what i'm
saying like you like if you're sub three
it was a choice it was a choice i'll
give you that is it better
yeah no it's better okay um
like just it just has most people just
have taken care of themselves to some
degree
don't look like garbage
most i would say four to six most people
like slightly below average yeah yeah
i'm like you're like 5 11 you're a
natural beauty there's no realm where
you're poor i can understand maybe you
took a bad photo and you didn't realize
there's a bad photo so someone might
like judge you yeah
well but that's the thing i don't i
don't like think it's like i'm not
sitting here oh no on the floor like sad
i'm just thinking okay don't use that
picture yeah
so that's like that's why that's why i
like the like apps or like the the
rating apps because i think it's like
helpful that's like how i think of it is
it's like a tool
but like at the end of the day it really
doesn't matter like
what anyone thinks like you just have to
find one person that finds you
attractive so what does it matter if
like the rest of the world like you know
guys that i was talking to because he
was doing the pet name thing like
wouldn't lay off right and he was coming
on very strong i'm like
and he's like well i'm just so attracted
to you i like you i'm like we haven't
even met right this is a dude we swiped
on the app and an app i was like we
haven't even
like
don't know anything about me well i find
you attractive i was like a lot of
people find me attractive mm-hmm that
do anything for me like yeah
other things that are actually like
about me of course you find me
attractive
yeah
no that's
that's like
okay what are you what she kind of looks
like melissa arnold
austin's girlfriend no
oh my gosh she totally kind of does our
old nanny i was actually oh actually i
have a disagreement for you that i
thought of from this is where the convo
gets good chat sure
um so i think you said to like do less
for guys
yeah
and i i actually like
i think for a guy of value like you
should do more
to be honest
a guy
no like a guy that you felt like a guy
that you like want and like want to
compete for like i think you should like
what
i have never been one to compete for a
man ever
yeah but no watch watch you also like
you've never had a boyfriend right yeah
so it's like i think like
you sold yourself no but this is this is
like terrible advice for a girl do
nothing yeah like for a guy that has
more that like would you okay what was
katie's her name yeah would you one of
the things you liked about katie that
you told me was that she was helpful
right yeah and she tries like yeah
and would you not like okay i'm not i'm
not gonna say anything like katie's very
attractive right but let's say you had
an option between a hotter girl that
does nothing and a less attractive girl
by far the less attractive yeah and
that's that's what i'm saying like i
don't think guys minimum like standard
of attractiveness that they require is
that high and i think you can compete
like more if you just are helpful and
nice and just a good person yes like
doesn't it's not that hard overall it's
just
the things that sometimes you have to do
things that you'll hate doing like
dishes with folding laundry like sorry
this big feminist movement of oh that's
not my job fine i
great example katie loves to cook
[ __ ] hate cooking i'm a terrible cook
and i burn mac and cheese
she loves to cook cooks for cooked all
weekend but i did all the dishes because
i i don't i like dishes it's just it's
calming it's easy and like the mindless
stuff just like
just
it's it's about the little trade-offs
and about finding someone that can do
the things that you hate that they're
good at yeah like mom and dad dad sucks
at marketing
it sucks he sucks at running yeah
running that aspect of it can run a
business pretty fairly well um bigger is
just putting him to actually get him to
do it yeah that was where mom came in
actually enforcing him doing it
getting him to do things
well and this is what i said about mom
and dad how did mom attain a guy that's
like a multi-millionaire right that's
that's rare right
right like how how did she marry him get
the tell like that that's that's like
every woman's dream this is but it
wasn't that she obtained him she built
him with him well i i know i know but
but he was making six figures when she
met him and she wasn't yeah he was ask
him oh he was making like at the
software company that he was working at
with his brother wow he i don't know if
it was six but it was close to it dad
told me no because he said he i don't
think so because he said he was only
making he was making more than grandpa
by like 10 grand but
yeah
he was making six figures within a year
of knowing her okay yes okay that i know
oh my okay this is my point yeah he it
was early on that she could see she got
him to marry her regardless okay and
what i'm saying is like but this is what
mom did
she did distance with him right and then
he said look it you could either move to
me or find a new boyfriend and she
dropped everything
followed him yeah and like you know some
people would think that's stupid but
like i don't think it is if it's the
right guy yeah i mean it's a risk yeah
yeah and it panned out for her right
but like she didn't do that but i think
i'm actually going to talk about this in
the live
like in order to like get because even
um
with one yeah like when i would ask him
like what made me like stand out from
like other girls you know uh like he
said um
it was like because you were so nice and
like so helpful
because i was like helping him with all
of this stuff like
you know before we were even like dating
you know
um so i don't know that's just like so
why do you think like you shouldn't do
anything for a guy because men want to
do for you
men as
men
want to do for the woman right they are
the ones
needed they want to feel like they can
come in and provide for you and and help
you do stuff and then you're doing
everything for them they're not really
going to feel like there's a place for
them and then you also end up in a room
where they walk all over you and expect
you to do everything for them and then
you become their mother and not their
girlfriend right well no i definitely
agree with you there but i think it's
like you kind of meet in the middle
somewhere
okay like i think like if you want him
to treat you like a queen you have to
treat him like a king
sure so like you know like like which
means like buying him gifts unexpectedly
or like cooking for him cleaning for
like you know and i'm not saying you
have to do that like your full-time job
but like i think guys want to be like
appreciated okay what did you think of
that yeah i mean i think you guys both
have the right perspective she's just
going to the extremes extreme opposites
because she's
never dated someone so she's never
really yeah i think a lot of her
i think a lot of her opinion in it is
just
she seems to sees the extremes because
she's afraid and she's afraid because
she's never done it and she's afraid of
the unknown which is perfectly
reasonable and
common but
it's that unknown that makes the
entertaining part of life
yeah and i think that's like what i
realized is like in dating i think we
all operate out of like fear like nobody
wants to be embarrassed you know like
guys don't want to feel used girls don't
want to feel used either guys don't want
to feel used for their resources girls
don't want to feel used for their body
right and so i feel like a lot of times
we go into this just like scared right i
agree um
but like you have to if you want
anything worth having like
you think mom like knew it was gonna
work out when she dropped everything
left like
follow dad no
but it's a risk
and now it like worked out yeah we're
pretty cool right
so i mean i cook i mean you know because
you came to my house yeah oh my gosh
you're a great cook actually
anytime anyone's coming over like man
female whoever like
you're gonna have being a good cook holy
that's so attractive like i took mrs sue
sex cooking it for advantage
like
well of course she's like the best
housewife ever like she's like uh
you know there's people that are
housewives and they're just lazy she's
like a professional housewife she does a
good job yeah i mean mister he's like
makes sick figures
yeah
and she has since she met her so it's
the same exact concept that mom and dad
spoke that we spoke about earlier made
by me so like i guess that already gives
me a lift up so i don't have to think
about that
yeah and sure like once i point where
i'm living with my man i'm going to be
doing the cooking and cleaning most
likely because
i want it done a certain way
okay it doesn't bother me
but when we're in recording stages
what i'm doing for you i'm giving you my
time i'm spending time and i'm trying
but you're both spending time i think
the time was pathetic it's an equal
investment the time is awful that's a
terrible thing appreciation by showing
up looking good and smelling good and if
that's not enough for you it'll
i'll get someone out basic hygiene i'll
give you part of that because most men
don't give a [ __ ] like i don't wear
deodorant
at all because i never smell bad because
i shower every day and i always make
sure that if i work out i shower
immediately after i i never smell bad
because i just don't have the
body hygiene that needs it okay fine
fine
but
for like most men they just like
there's a great tweet um
she spends 800 bucks on nails dresses
and all the nice stuff and then the men
it switches to the men's perspective
goes huh i should probably shower just
in case my balls end up in her mouth
like okay okay let me ask you this do
you care if um
if they have fake nails and like like
dyed their hair haircut like does that
matter to you not really okay so we do
that for us why do why does he have to
like why does that matter if you're
doing it for yourself
i think there's a little bit of value to
it um
you can look really good with it it's
the yeah
i think you can't i just think like most
guys don't care that much
i don't think like if she if um katie
showed up on your first date or however
you guys met super dressed up or like
you know in a normal outfit i think you
would have been attracted to her either
way yeah she's normal outfit yeah and
like it's just that okay yeah is she low
maintenance yeah i wouldn't i don't i
would never
like oh my gosh even a girl's nail habit
you know how expensive that is yeah she
she actually just cut clipped my
oh my gosh no
i like i think like no okay because okay
think about it like if you have like
let's say you have a guy and he's
talking to like three different girls
right
like i i like genuinely and genuinely
think like if you're the one that's like
going out of your way to like make him
feel special like you're gonna have a
leg up over like the other two girls
rather than the one who's just doing
nothing
okay even in like the courting phases so
like
true okay like imagine if you like
dropped off like this is a guy he's
talking to three different girls but
you're the one who made him like a
special gift right and you just drop it
off at his work to be nice
like i bet that's gonna go a long way
this weekend she um last weekend
completely took care of me everything
everything paid for made dinner did
everything because i came down to visit
and she said that was the return that
she expected and like yeah
like when i i have other females that
i've gone to visit out and like it was
that one time just that was all it took
and i was like i don't really want to
see you again yeah you didn't do [ __ ] i
came all this way to come visit you yeah
and like all you did was made me dinner
one day yeah well cause girls think they
could just like exist yeah like and that
was it and that was like she had a lot
more value to just not doing anything i
was like yeah
okay no okay this is an example that it
didn't happen to me but
um the most recent season of the
bachelor with the guy matt james right
in his like final three the chick
one of the chicks
made him
special like
jerseys that said mr and mrs james and
she got him this whole little gift and
this is before he like got down in the
final two and she was like you know i
just really wanted to tell you how much
i appreciate you how much i you know i'm
falling in love with you blah blah blah
he was like thank you for the gift and
broke up with her in that moment and
then wait oh is that michelle yeah
and then he picked the chick who did
literally nothing who sat in the corner
and was quiet the entire time
yeah but i think he liked her from the
beginning like i think like
it doesn't really
it doesn't there's aspects of everything
that are missing you only get to see
whatever the editor should see and it's
not real life i hate the bachelor and
all that stuff for that exact reason
what guy how many guys have 20 girls
competing with
for him
like okay like you're probably in the
top like probably like 10 of height
right yeah maybe even more
right
sorry his girl you guys watching his
girlfriend is or girlies okay i don't
know whatever you want to call it okay
um how many before before her when you
were just like talking to girls whatever
how many girls were you talking to at
the same time
like actively like hanging out with
four to five right that's not 20. right
so like what are the odds out of the
four to five that all of them are like
nice kind you know what i mean granted i
don't find
i don't think any of the bachelors have
been that attractive overall
but
i could totally see
like if the bachelor because the
bachelor they don't play on any of the
stipulations of what they make of any of
that stuff do they
they probably pick a guy that makes a
lot of money i can't imagine they don't
yeah
or at least a good like a good enough
job i don't know there's a lot more to
it and like that's
i just have a problem with it because
all you're seeing is whatever the
editors want you to see and that's
nah
like if they like you they like you you
don't have to do all the extras to like
sway them into liking you
like
when when that happened it was such a
crazy like the same like me and you
signed in the video at the same time
man she really thought she was about to
be mrs james she got all this [ __ ]
monogrammed and everything and he was
like
and he literally just left her like
right there
yeah but that's like reality tv you know
like that's not like men and women okay
i'll give i'll give you an example right
my mom and my this is how my mom got to
date a guy in the top half a percent of
men okay right i mean he was like like
in terms of you can skip through this i
think we know the story
right and she she was um
okay
so they like both stayed sorry what with
that being said they like
the problem is like
you can like anybody i'll put that put
it this way you can like anybody i i've
met so many people well i lived
different random locations i've lived
and like i've met a ton of people i
liked people i didn't like just off one
encounter and then i might have met him
again and i was like oh these people are
not that bad oh they're pretty cool
they're actually really bad i don't
regret that decision like
there's there's that line but like it's
putting a little bit of extra work in a
little bit of extra effort that actually
makes them like you reconsider like go
ahead all right how about
okay this doesn't well i think we're
told from like movies that oh guy sees
girl and is immediately obsessed and
wants to pursue her and like she knew
she was the one right away i'm like i
don't think that's real no like like
katie i've been i've known her for like
two years now and just
i just continued friendly conversation
consistently but like
never really pursued it heavily just
always left the option open and like it
it was just a little bit of the little
things that you just start doing and
start
picking up on and actually starting move
forward with that's the ones that
actually start to get hey this person
actually should mean something
and it's the consistency two of them
it's not just the one time that's the
other thing is um
men fall like girls fall in love their
sex and men fall in love through like
quality time and loyalty yeah
like your business i'm gonna go do that
and like that's how she got like a top
percentage of man is because like other
girls would probably say no i'm not i'm
gonna put like myself first i'm not
gonna like and like and i think like a
lot of times like as women like we look
at girls that don't have to like
okay
all right guys
uh i'm gonna skip ahead
to
i think it's around the 30 minute mark
like can i do your laundry can i make
you dinner
okay this is the part i wanted to show
you i didn't realize how long like the
beginning was oh
that's after like they've been in there
i'm sure they were exclusive after the
yeah
um is there any other topics you want to
talk about
we should talk about cuffing season
that's what i'm all about right now
coughing season
how are you it's like when you people
just tend to get in a relationship right
before the holidays are you in the do
you have any prospects
i do
one of them is one of the ones that was
texting me just before messing up the
live
oh yeah
what is he like how old he's 39
yeah
she's he's white yeah
i'm too young for the age difference he
has like a corporate job five years for
me is significant
oh i wouldn't care yeah okay 21 to 30
year old oh yeah
me to greg
yeah but a 30 year old would date a 21
year old if his girl the guy like girl
was younger
usually i still don't find that okay
he's nice he's not like
i just went away for a week for like a
work trip and he's not like blowing up
my phone like being annoying which is
really nice i need
that sort of sort of space
back he's he's immediately like i'm
gonna let's celebrate like i want to
take you out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one okay yeah we went on one
right before i left that was our first
first date
date
i'm confused what
she like immediately immediately after
she gets back blows up
well that's how i was confused she's
like oh he's not blowing up my phone i'm
like well clearly like you went on what
date you're also very far away and
if i'm thinking about having a girl for
sex frequently i'm like all right i'll
hit you up when i'm in town yeah
go ahead sorry so now we'll go i guess
on the second one
but he's kind of short he's only five
nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really
you're too short for me young girl
manifesting a tall man one of the other
guys i'm talking to is six foot seven
oh wow
he's a tall boy which i'll say talking
to but it's not even talking to like
you've been on like one date i would
never like
i'd consider that talking okay well but
the thing is when you're older it's off
of like ass yeah that's you're awesome
it's significantly different it's not
like talking to you like at a co like
that's such a different social
environment
and we'll be going out soon it's just a
matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
mm-hmm
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tic-tac about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] kissing you you're
not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're required well she also works
at like festivals and i'm like you can
literally sneak in there and not be
vaccinated my problem with it is that
like there's no test so
if
we're not we're not we're not going on
to the vaccine argument on youtube we're
not working with vaccination that's
where i am right now holding all this
laundry i don't know all these music
festivals where they're requiring proof
of vaccination and to me it's so much
deeper than just like do you or don't
you it's about that like i don't want to
have that debate with you right like
clearly
if we don't view it the same way we're
not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not gonna date
a white republican that would just be a
headache like why would we do that to
ourselves
okay friends we wouldn't travel in the
same circles and we don't view this the
world the same way i actually agree with
that
i think yeah like why would we do that
to ourselves i think if you're someone
that sits in the middle like me you
should because you don't know where you
are well in the middle is fine but if
you if you're super left like why would
you date someone super right
i think
so i have a little bit of an incentive
to do that just for the fact that i love
to argue i love the aspect of just hey
can we discuss this debate this versus
like i don't i guess i don't like
argument like discussion and debates
yeah and like the consistent idea of
being completely opposite with somebody
it just it entices me because it's like
then you can see the best of both worlds
you can see both sides and like yeah i
just like that i don't know so i wanted
to use the world same as me and even if
you're not the same mentality
she couldn't she couldn't have this yeah
mentality of shut down you'd have to
have the same hey you actually wanted to
talk about this and like you can agree i
can agree that i don't like your opinion
but
i'm not going to change anything about
me for it i'd still like you as a person
overall yeah well i mean
clearly like i dated someone with a
political difference yeah although he
he kind of switched when he had to pay
taxes for the first time
i don't know in my opinion it's just
kind of giggly
it makes me laugh okay black but you're
white and you like get and understand
the black struggle fine that's fine
um but yeah i definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just
why bother and having those arguments
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
um
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
even have a car i was like how are you
coming to take me out you don't have a
car you know i'm not driving anywhere
yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car um i've also realized
that i want someone that has like some
sort of creative or like
job and entertainment like i have
um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to be like you
know we'll spend our days or whatever
separately and then at the end of the
night i want us to be able to come
together and talk about all the exciting
things that happen in each of our lives
right like okay this other guy was like
well i'm not rich i'm a regular guy and
i was like that's fine but like i'm not
a regular girl
like
i'm i'm not so like if you're if you are
gonna date me like either you have to be
able to handle that or you yourself also
have to not be like regular like i don't
think i'm like just an average
i think everyone's regular
i don't know
i was just thinking a pretty regular guy
like you know what i was thinking i was
like i literally like
what is not regular yeah that's like
like i could i know a few people that
are regular but like they're in like
that's a word but i don't mean this is
an insult like i'm i'm regular like i'm
a regular person yeah
i think i'm a little odd you know i
think i'm i'm unique i think all of us
are yeah like i think we're all kind of
like funny like entertaining
but does that mean i'm not a normal
person
like
what is
if
you are
and we're talking dating like the only
way you could not be regular is if
you're like crazy hot like eight or
higher
yeah even though i'd still say you're
pretty regular um if you're
if you talk to her again ask her what
her version her thought of what a
regular person is okay like their their
salary their standard of living their
day-to-day i want you're gonna see this
later but i bet it's gonna be funny
so you'll see like that is boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
he wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an eight
carat question cut vintage engagement
ring if you make forty five thousand
dollars a year it would take what
four years no eight years
how much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street
okay if you if you had okay bro i would
never like
two you had the girl of your dreams i'll
buy you a house for 200 happily
what are those the rings that you suck
on oh
yeah let's get let's get two ring pops
to buy a 200 grit house and i'll put it
in your name and everything i i'm okay
with that screw the tournament up grand
ring what is that gonna bring you along
and here's the thing like you probably
will make a lot of money someday and
this is this is you're gonna what's the
value of that ring what will it bring
you other than looks other than the look
what will it bring you that's it it's
good blind people that's so superficial
yeah that's like so superficial but it's
about so much more than that it's about
the fact that you can afford that right
i go together it's about money yeah
that's being superficial again this girl
has an eight-carat diamond i wish i
pushed back but i was just in shock
company and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that okay
well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot you
should have asked her also
so
if he makes 45 grand now but you have no
idea what to make in the future
45 grand and if you ask for that 100
ring
and but got that 100 ring
then in the future five years from now
when he's making two million dollars
then if you ask for that 200 000 ring
fine i agree i was trying to think how
much was mom's ring worth do you think
that dad got it not much it was less
than the biggest the last one wasn't
even worth i don't think he's bought a
ring over 20 grand okay but it was it
was still expensive like i was still i
don't like 200k i was like i don't think
he's gotten momma more than 20 grand
yeah he might have and mom isn't like
she's not mad about it she she was more
amazed that she kind of was second rate
that's
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling you
but not not in a good way not in a good
way i'm telling you like my dad would
but if my mom asked for that from my dad
my dad would have told her to go find a
new boyfriend because there was no way
in hell he was gonna spend two hundred
thousand dollars on an engagement ring
and that's something
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had ten kids my
mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
diamonds appreciate but the the
percentage for a high is like five
percent
like you realize that's
that's dog [ __ ]
that's 210 currency and the currency
like you may that ring will give you 210
grand after 50 years
my house in angola it's already gone up
in value buy that 10 grand
in a year
but like
no it's just like a practicality no it's
like aspects and that's what i say like
do you know what they always say to her
channel y'all are rich but you look poor
[ __ ] i didn't even have a shirt on
either costco
this is like saying like all my shirts
are still from high school that's what
people don't understand about like
people that like have money don't spend
it like that usually
usually there's some like there's a
percentage that do but not but if you
look at that percentage they'll never be
in the top
out of the top percentage they'll never
be in the top 10. look at mark
zuckerberg he wears a t-shirt with the
same t-shirt
and that's like human and dope can be
wrong they spend money like houses but
they spend it on good [ __ ] yeah like the
things that they'll spend a lot of money
on are suits which i'm sorry good suit
that's that helps a lot
certain things help a lot and that's
those are
those are the basic stepping stones that
you need
versus things so
just sounds like not like real to me you
know really yeah like i don't know for
me like i told you like my my
status was going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend you know what
it means like i need somebody who can be
on that level right i'm like i should
have said this like taylor you sell
glitter
like that's what she does like it's cool
that you make that amount of money but
it doesn't make you better than all
these guys
but the problem is like guys don't care
about your money
right there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this cr like
to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
let me just my minimum standard is the
multi-millionaire let's just see if the
universe provides like this
oh my gosh but then like you're half
your your full standard has to be the
billionaire like
let's just i'll just get it i'll get my
minimum standard is your dating coach
married yes and she has a baby and her
wedding ring is at least five carats
yeah
and her man is rich and she's even happy
okay you know he herself makes like 30
to 50 grand a month
coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like i
looked up this dating coach right i was
like i gotta see this
i gotta see this lady
um and she's like
you know i could
hold on let me see
that's so painful
and she's cute like she but she like
honestly i'm just being honest like the
reason the girl got that is because i
could tell like
i'm sure when she got like this is the
girl do you think she got pregnant early
no i mean
i mean she married like the nerdy guy
which is totally cool and like she's
more attractive than him i think like
yeah i know my wife
she's supposed to be but like
i'm not trying to be mean but like you
kind of get what you get based on like
partially how pretty you are yeah so
like you can't that'd be like me saying
all these girls that get like flying
flown out and like get everything paid
for by these like super rich guys like i
like am i gonna expect that now
you know um
oh my god like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are going to hear that and be like
no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with me maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance
if they ask
hey that conversation is gonna barely if
not if ever gonna get brought up so
that's where she'll get lucky on that
aspect if she brought up that aspect of
of
her every single time
good luck honey because that man has to
be committed
you are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
what
i'm going to try i was trying to be nice
they want girls hotter
yeah like they want they want a hot like
tell me if i'm wrong i just think like
guys that make that amount of money they
don't marry young right
if they tend like once they get there
like if dad were to get remarried
someday like he'd probably find a girl
like more young
oh they married young and came up
together i'm saying like men that are
established and have that amount of
money they want a hot 22 to 27 year old
right but
it's also dead so he would never let
that level of oh i'll put it pretentious
but that's probably not the right word
um
oh no he would he would never but that's
what i'm saying like
i try to say this like nicely but i'm
like oh you don't qualify for those guys
you can try let me know if it works out
but yeah she's 30 and hasn't had a
boyfriend like yeah that's what i'm
saying like it shows it's not working
it's like something's not working well
it's because like it's the crazy high
standards i'm not saying you you won't
ever fall in love or find someone i'm
saying good luck finding a guy to buy
you a 200 000 engagement ring that's
what i'm saying
does that make sense you agree or do you
disagree
i think sh as a guy your guy's
perspective she might she might find him
i think her odds are actually high that
she'll find a guy that'll do that i
think it's just going to be a few years
after
he does that like it's he's not going to
do
she wants a little bit too here now
versus
not understand it will take time if she
wants someone to do that she want she's
that eight years for example that guy
that makes 40 50 grand a year eight
years
oh so you're saying like get with the
guy that makes less money and then work
up to that which might happen and then
her standards might change and she might
go yeah that was actually that was a bad
idea i realized why that was a waste of
money now and then she goes all right
yes
then i think that'll be what changes
i don't think it'll i mean i'm just
being honest i don't think it'll happen
because she doesn't have the right
mindset going in 200 no this is this is
like let's say let's say like with her
like the way she looks like like 30. i
don't i don't think it's over but i
think it's over if your mentality is oh
let me do nothing and just exist and
hope a guy that's making millions of
dollars falls in love with me
like that combined with the mentality do
you know what i'm saying yeah would you
agree or disagree no i agree like that's
why i don't think it's going to happen
for her because like it's the mentality
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids it's
literally not like like you're literally
the most fertile like
it's like 35 when women stop starts
i know
that's what like we don't why don't we
tell them
like 30s like in my opinion 30s almost
too late but i also want more than two
kids right right that's what i'm saying
like guys that have made money like they
want a young girl so they can have a lot
of kids because they're done with the
money part like they're pretty i don't
care
look at that he just kept pumping
i feel like dad did not want that many
goals
i actually i think he did i just think
he got sick of it yeah i think he's like
oh what happened
initially he was like oh yeah keep going
yep another one let's go let's go whoa
whoa whoa
and then he then like it kept going he's
like oh no
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me like
that's like dragon morgan they just got
married right i think they've done it
perfect i think they did it ideally
because morgan only wants two kids
and she's 30.
that's that's exactly what you want
right and they they made their money
they figure out where they want to live
in life to figure out how they want to
live in life yeah i think that's perfect
but they also did it over eight years
nine years oh my gosh i think as a woman
that's unwise to stay that long
typically i think she's the exception
not the rule
why
why because i think
um you don't want to waste your youth
i think she might have well
i think she's the exception not the rule
that's what i'm saying i think if a guy
typically waits that long to marry you
like
help it's because
there are children
who are they they're the neighbors kids
i'm being chased yeah get out i don't
want to see them i'm doing a video
i do not want to see them but i don't
know i do understand they're like
there's like legal reasons guys don't
get married but yeah there's a lot
there's a lot with that um i think
part of it is they didn't really waste
their youth look it they but everywhere
because it worked out for her but if it
didn't
then she would be 30 in a rush
and that's it explored the world yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying like yeah
greg did it right yeah great
yeah
i'm saying like it was it was just a
high risk for morgan i think because if
that like if that didn't work out for
greg he could have like he has time
women don't have time right
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say a musical artist
right a musical producer somebody who's
in entertainment somebody who's on a tv
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
easy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it
no but like i this is something coming
from someone like i've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
gee he's awesome like he also dated
hazel
like why do you think you're on this
like
yeah like i but i would never in a
million years ask him to spend 200k on a
rank because he probably wouldn't take
it either like
like that's what i'm saying i was like
girl like
like i've literally been in a
relationship with someone that's a
millionaire
i would never
never like in a million years
ask them to do that like i know he
offered to get me a ring and if i didn't
go to england yeah like that's upside
like i couldn't but
i'm just not that type of person i'm not
gonna like
that's like that's almost like entitled
like i'm not entitled to his money
i mean
here's the thing
i can afford it right yeah that's like
entirely that was good
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
gonna need to be buying me diamonds for
every anniversary
or
spend two hundred thousand dollars on
one
will bring all the time like get me my
ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else okay i
think
the perspective she's trying to feed
into was that she
won't
she wants the one thing and that's
because she wants it i
i'm starting to understand a little more
but it's still painful like she wants
something big that she wants she can
keep
well okay and this is okay cause that's
like pretty much it they're like we talk
about other stuff but like
lady
like
i just oh my god
that's painful yeah
like i i was thinking like i hope you
don't want jewelry every anniversary but
even when i was talking i was like put
it in the college fund she's like oh
we'll have that too i'm like
like lady i come from money like
like i probably met more like high value
men than you've ever met like i've
talked to them like my brother's all i
was i realized i was
i i ruined like the streak of everyone
making six figures
or close to it right
no i don't know you're still young yeah
i mean i hope so eventually but i'm
saying like i realized that the other
day i was like damn i ruined like the
six figure streak
in our family that we haven't got yeah
for now we'll see um but times to tell
but this is what i was saying though um
he
and i'm like lady like
you're not even asking me any questions
when i like grew up around these guys
that make the kind of money you're
you're like telling me
what they want you're not asking me any
questions
and you're telling me what they want i'm
like and i talked to her she like didn't
grow up with like a dad in the house
which is i'm not trying to throw that in
your face but i'm saying like
i'd lose so much value in a moment like
there there's a level of didn't grow up
with the dad in the house or did just
never liked him
like
that's about the same value to me
versus i grew up with a stepfather who
i grew up with multiple fathers but
they're all awesome and like they did
their best to raise me is good yeah
that's awesome that that that woman as
good as the person with the dad well and
it shows you like like there was another
interview where i was talking to her
about like men's problems she's like
what problems that don't have any
problems and i was like
um okay paternity tests like fathering
kids that aren't theirs who's the guy um
like there's a one one guy
like court like child custody like i'm
looking involved
there's one guy
thinks about this pretty heavily and
but you know what i'm saying like you
can hear it in the way that she talks
that she like doesn't
like you don't you don't mean like i
could sit here and say oh dad was gone a
lot growing up because like you know he
worked and i could like i could have
that out like a negative outlook yeah
but i don't like i say no my dad's great
like even though maybe like he wasn't
around as much when i was a kid like i
get all the time i want with him now
yeah if i really want it sometimes i'm
like i gotta go yeah
you know what i mean though yeah like i
can go and make it like i'm so lucky but
like
that like oh my gosh sorry i'm like even
watching this back i'm getting
frustrated
i can't find it
um
this dude
it's gonna kill me
i'm gonna find this video and i want you
to watch it later on he
he talks about how male privilege in the
world doesn't really exist because
it or in the u.s sorry not the world
that's poor
um
in certain countries obviously it does
the
it's like
males have majority of the suicide rate
males have a majority of um dying in
combat males have the majority of
frontline defenders males have the
majority of um labor jobs males have the
majority of
they're just like you just the list goes
on forever like fine males have the
majority of wealth in the country yeah
okay look at those men and look at their
wives and look at look at everything
that led into that and then you look at
how many of those men exist
that percentage sucks i'm sorry
that sucks it
that total
number of people up there that kept that
small group of people
shouldn't be your number and most
statistical analysis it would barely
count as an outlier like it
that's how bad it is because
as a group of people there's just not
that many people up there and
being that it's one percent the one
percent if the one percent truly rule
the world then as a statistic they don't
even actually get factored in usually
because with the with the statistics you
usually have a 95 percent 98 or 99
so like you're
if they're accounted they're barely
accounted for and that's what i always
think like girls look at like the top
small percentage of men that do have
like all the leverage in society right
and right like you know dude i mean like
they have a lot of money they have a lot
of power like they have no reason to be
faithful to their wife right and and you
know and we like think i don't want to
say we cause i'm not included but like
girls think that's all guys but i'm like
if you're born like below average height
as a guy like that's hard that's like
genuinely like girls like overlook you
treat you as like as if you're sub-human
a lot of the time and so do other men oh
i mean guys yeah and guys do that to
like heavy girls i think it's kind of
the equivalent but that's a choice kind
of i disagree with that a little bit
more i think they do it to
louder
girls
oh like
just people who are
who just like
very pushy about who they are yeah and
just very hey this is who i am i don't
give a [ __ ] what you are this is what
i'm gonna do this is yeah i would like
to i don't need a man tired yeah
okay guys sorry this is a long ass
discussion uh let me know i could be
tripping right i could be wrong so let
me know like about
what your thoughts are on this
interaction let me know if you think
adam represents guys or you think
you know
he's tripping too let us know in the
comments
brother brother sister duo a lot of fun
i'll talk to you guys next time